nothing says fancy dining quite like a
blob of foam
well that and when waiters sweep up your
breadcrumbs with that tiny scoop but
back to the foam so soothing such a
great mouthfeel and get this you can
make it at home fancy restaurants be
damned
you'll need a whipping siphon first of
all also a liquid juice perhaps and the
secret ingredient gelatin that'd be the
collagen protein from animal hides and
bones by the way so what's so magical
about that gelatin what's happening is
the proteins are forming a film around
air bubbles this both gives the foam
support and keeps the bubbles from
merging with each other to form ever
larger bubbles the more gelatin the more
protein and the thicker your phone now
you'll need to figure out how thick you
want your phone really thick foam will
be 2.5% gelatin while 1.5 percent
gelatin will get you medium thickness
the thinnest foam for cocktails or such
is known by the horrible name espuma
that's just 3/4 of 1% gelatin start by
heating up your liquid of choice then
just add your sheets of gelatin and stir
until they dissolve easy chill over an
ice bath and pour into your whipping
siphon charge the siphon up and give it
a good shake you've got yourself some
pro grade culinary foam we recommend
going thicker though so you can avoid
saying the word espuma